Supreme Court Justice Samuel Alito is
facing scrutiny over a new report
claiming he accepted a lavish vacation
from a conservative billionaire with
frequent business before the court it's
a story written up by propublica and it
comes as some are calling for reform to
the high Court's ethics Scott McFarland
is at the Supreme Court for us this
morning with more Scott Good morning
Tony good morning Tuesday's report
claims Justice Alito took a luxury
fishing trip with Republican Mega donor
Paul singer but didn't recuse himself
years later when cases connected to
singer's business came here before the
high court even before the reporting was
published Alito was mounting a response
the report says justice Samuel Alito did
not report gifts on annual Financial
disclosure forms including a private
flight to Alaska and other amenities
provided by billionaire hedge fund
manager Paul singer during a fishing
trip in 2008. the report details that in
July of that year they stayed at the
king salmon Lodge and were served
multi-course meals of Alaskan king crab
legs or Kobe filet they also enjoyed
wine that cost one thousand dollars a
bottle according to propublica singers
manhattan-based hedge fund was involved
in at least 10 cases brought before The
Supreme Court many of them high stakes
business cases those cases were heard
after that fishing trip in 2008 with one
decision in 2014 when the high court
voted seven to one in singer's favor and
Justice Alito did not recuse himself
from any of them in an op-ed published
hours before pro-publica's report
Justice Alito denied what he dubbed
charges made against him in reference to
the ride on that private plane Alito
said that singer allowed me to occupy
what would have otherwise been an
unoccupied seat and that he stayed in a
modest one-room unit Alito wrote that he
followed but I understood to be standard
practice by excluding the flight from
his financial report
Alito is the latest Justice to respond
to claims of undisclosed gifts and
luxury travel earlier this spring
Democrats in Congress called on Justice
Clarence Thomas to step down after
propublica reported he'd accepted
Decades of luxury travel from a donor
it's important to note the judicial
conference just recently required
justices to disclose travel
accommodations to social events Gail
all right Scott got it thank you